in this morning's ion money how changes
in the formula for the country's most
widely used credit score could affect
millions of Americans today the company
that turns your credit history into
what's known as the FICO score has just
announced that it's updating how that
number is calculated Thank You patty
this comes as a new report shows the
average u.s. FICO score hit an all-time
high of 703 last year that is considered
a good score
FICO scores are used to determine
whether you can receive a new credit
card get a home or auto loan so it's
important CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with the change what
it means for you so when do they make
the change and why do they make the
change well they made the change
recently this happens every five years
so this is rude it's a regular thing
they shift the algorithm and so the
folks from FICO said like it was a
normal process a lot of credit analysts
that I spoke to said it also may be that
some of their clients the big banks and
financial institutions wanted to see
what would happen if the economy were to
sour because what what changes did they
do specific so the big change is that if
you are expanding the amount of money
you're borrowing or late on a payment
it's gonna hurt you more under the new
system and this goes into effect for the
summer time I should say and that's
really interesting because what does it
sort of it creates a world of haves and
have-nots if your score is good you're a
good payer it's okay your scores
probably going to improve but if you are
a little bit late and that has happened
more recently that could hurt you the
other thing they've done is they've
added installment or personal loans as a
bit of a negative in some cases that
those have become very popular as people
said I want to pay off my credit card
I'm gonna get a fixed loan they also are
taking a longer window to look at your
credit payment history so previously
they might have looked at the last month
or two months now they're going back 30
months so that they can see a pattern
think of the credit scoring system in
some cases that's like an early warning
system to the big banks for us it's
really important as you said because we
use it to gain so much of their
borrowing power so it means basically
you know anybody who's looking for a
loan is gonna be affected by this yeah
it will be now the actual institutions
can choose the old scoring method
they are going to have this information
it's interesting when we spoke to FICO
yesterday we got a statement from them
they said 110 million consumers they
will see their scores changed by less
than 20 points so not a big shift but
another 80 million are going to see
scores jump or drop by more than 20
points split evenly between people doing
with better scores and we're so easy to
improve your score Gail I mean Gail oh
my god it's like for me so easy to mess
up your credit is just a couple of
payments and then before you know it
your name you're on the dead to me list
it's very different it's so true and it
takes a while so the FICO score is
determined by five different factors the
two most important things are do you pay
your bills on time so if you want to
improve your score making payments
automatic pages I've done I know
absolutely and as much as possible you
want to set it up on an automatic
payment also the total amount that you
have outstanding in credit there are
other things your credit history or the
types of credit those are the two
Biggie's so be careful pay those bills
on time you'll be better off borrowing
money from friends yeah no you know what
I used to do back in the day I would put
the light bill to the cable bill and
then you say oh that was my mistake I'm
so sorry
they call that a Gail can you not do
that that's not good